[Música]
así que aprendizaje permanente es el
tema de hoy y que desafío sobre todo
porque es permanente y eso implica un
montón de tiempo piensan lo primero que
pensaba cuando venía para acá creo que
la presión en inglés le hace mucho más
honor a esta sensación porque es
lifelong learning es decir aprendizaje
durante toda la vida un montón de tiempo
hoy yo quisiera ser foco con ustedes en
un momento muy concreto de ese montón de
tiempo que es bastante particular porque
todos los estamos por acá o lo pasamos o
lo vamos a pasar
qué es ese momento que pasamos de la
escuela al trabajo esos dos mundos y
nuestra transición
es bastante particular además porque no
es igual para todos pero es para todos
al reto con los diecinueve años después
de haber hecho 12 años de educación
primaria y secundaria en uruguay y el
año y medio de haber iniciado mi carrera
universitaria algunos amigos me tocó un
poco antes y algunos amigos un poco
después incluso si le preguntan a sus
padres un poquito demasiado después en
particular además porque no está claro
cuándo termina el espacio cuando empieza
a otros decir cuándo termina la
educación y cuándo empieza a trabajar
más bien lo que sucede es que se solapan
dos espacios de aprendizajes muy
concretos como son el aula y el trabajo
y lo cierto es que esta transición no
parece salirnos del todo bien en uruguay
sé que cada diez jóvenes no terminan la
educación media superior y uno de cada
cuatro que busca empleo no lo encuentran
entonces en esta transición muchos
jóvenes lo que terminan realmente
encontrándose es una pared muy grande y
muy ancha que sólo algunos pueden saltar
con éxito
creo además que hay dos elementos que
hacen más complejos esta transición que
ya fueron mencionados pero que quiero
repasar brevemente y el primero de ellos
es que cada vez vamos a vivir más según
el banco mundial la esperanza de vida al
nacer para la costa rica está en el
entorno de 80 años en uruguay es un
poquitito menor pero es un montón de
tiempo y cada vez es más entonces si nos
ponemos a pensar el tiempo que va a
estar aprendiendo en aula en clase es
creativamente menor y cada vez menor
y el segundo desafío que me parece que
tiene este esto es que el resto del
tiempo lo voy a pasar aprendiendo en
otros espacios y el trabajo seguramente
sea uno de ellos que ocupe además un
montón de tiempo otro elemento que ya se
adelantó terminator haga que creo que lo
hace bastante complejo es esta imagen de
que nos invaden las máquinas y nos
invaden los robots hay mil imágenes y
podemos usar mil fotos pero creo que lo
mejor que pueden hacer es salir de acá y
preguntarle a sus padres a sus abuelos
de qué trabajaban cuál fue su primer
trabajo cuáles en las primeras
actividades que hacían y traten de ver
si esas actividades siguen existiendo
hoy o si se hacen igual
en mi caso y sin ser tan viejo espero mi
primer trabajo fue poner en planillas de
excel cifras de balances de bancos
apasionantes no saben cómo me divertía
estoy seguro que hoy eso ya no lo hace
más una persona no es una computadora y
esa persona se dedica a otras cosas pero
hay otra manera de ver esta invasión de
los robots que me parece que es bastante
más entusiasmante y si me permite la
encontró una una investigación de dos
universidades australianas y ford que
lista no se tomó el trabajo de dictar
los 100 empleos del futuro y tras alguno
de los que me parecieron más locos yo no
sé ustedes pero no pudo salir de
operador turístico espacial
y vamos a tener que hacer para hacer ese
trabajo qué habilidades vamos a precisar
creo que no tenemos mucha idea tenemos
algunas nociones pero lo cierto que es
lo desconocido si no nos estamos
formando para los desconocidos
y yo vengo de un país que tiene una
especial obsesión por los títulos de la
educación formal casi como si la
condición necesaria es suficiente para
por desarrollarme en sociedad sea el
bendito título de la universidad y no
digo que no es importante que nombre
malinterpreten digo que no es suficiente
y en base a esto que venimos
compartiendo es un medio tan importante
como tantos otros y yo fui parte de esto
desde mi carga universitaria corrí atrás
de ese título dije bueno esto es lo que
preciso aprender me llevo cuatro años
con estos conocimientos me alcanzan
aprendo esto ya está sabe hasta cuándo
me duró eso hasta que empecé a trabajar
y ahí me di cuenta de la cantidad cosas
que había aprendido y no sabía usar la
cantidad cosas que había aprendido y no
funcionaba igual que en clase y la
cantidad cosa que tenía que aprender
para desarrollarme en el trabajo y md
cuenta de una cosa si yo no veo mi
espacio de trabajo en un espacio de
aprendizaje estoy perdido y eso dependía
esencialmente
como hacemos entonces para prepararnos
decir cuál es la mejor manera de
enfrentarse a este mundo si tenemos que
elegir una sola habilidad cuál sería o
incluso cuál sería el criterio para
elegir esa habilidad y se me ocurrió uno
tratemos de elegir una habilidad que no
pierda valor es decir que no expire que
a pesar de que todo esté cambiando todo
el tiempo y creo que esa habilidad es
aprender a aprender
es decir si nos vamos a enfrentar a
conocimiento nuevo para actividades
nuevas no puedo perder la capacidad de
aprender y ojo bueno digo no solo no
perderla sino que hable de cultivarla y
de desarrollarla
y no voy a descubrir yo el debate sobre
cuál es el vínculo entre el aula y el
trabajo en esta aproximación ni tampoco
pienso cerrarlo en estos minutos porque
no tengo muy claro cuál es la distancia
óptima entre estos dos mundos lo que sí
tengo muy claro es que parece estar
demasiado separados y que ya es hora de
que ensayemos alguna alternativa su
trabajo en uruguay en un proyecto que se
llama anima que estamos intentando desde
hace cuatro años ensayar esta
alternativa acercando los involucrados
para que trabajen juntos porque al final
van juntos creando una propuesta
educativa técnica para jóvenes de
contexto vulnerable que inserta dentro
de la currícula semanal las prácticas
formativas en empresas
y es en base a este trabajo que estaba
haciendo estos últimos años que quisiera
compartir algunas reflexiones con los
tres involucrados que creo que son parte
de este problema las aulas los jóvenes y
las empresas
el primer actor entonces las aulas y acá
sólo me va a permitir hacerme algunas
preguntas de mi propia trayectoria
educativa me gustaría que si ustedes
también se siente identificados con eso
puedan levantar la mano cuántos de
ustedes estudiaron de memoria un montón
de frases letras letras griegas de
memoria para ubicarlos arriba una hoja
de examen y que si les pregunto al
salido de la clase que escribiste ni
idea cuanto a ustedes en cuanto a
ustedes se sentarán en fila mirando al
profe hacia adelante corriendo para
sacar apuntes para notar textual lo que
dice el profe para después memorizar lo
entero
- bueno hablando de los tiene la mani
incluso en uruguay en algunos lugares de
clase el profe se tiene que parar una
tarima para escribir en el pizarrón para
que todos los alumnos miren el único
punto de donde sale el conocimiento
qué pasa con esto cuando termine la
educación formal como enseña esto
aprender y me parece súper relevante
esta pregunta en un contexto donde la
inserción social que debiera ser el fin
de la educación está mediada por la
inserción laboral exitosa si en un mundo
de las respuestas no son únicas y
tampoco son las maneras de llegar a esas
respuestas y creo que el desafío a
cadeca de los profes y en los que damos
clases tratando de generar ambientes más
reales no más difíciles más reales de
clases capaces de entusiasmar al alumno
y entusiasmando al alumno entusiasmarnos
a nosotros sus 160 seas más para enseñar
a aprender segundo actor que ustedes los
jóvenes los que están acá
y ahí me hubiera encantado encontrar una
guía para enseñarles a aprender y no sé
muy bien cuáles los pasos que hay que
seguir y ahí me volvió una frase esas
que hemos escuchado millones de veces y
que no pierde valor siempre tiene algo
nuevo para decirnos que me gustaría que
aparezca en este momento de tanto que la
he escuchado
que es conócete a ti mismo se ha
escuchado más de una vez y creo que es
bien importante conocerse a sí mismo por
dos motivos en este contexto el primero
solo podemos aprender aquello que nos
gusta aquello que nos apasiona que nos
genera la necesidad de entender lo demás
si lo podemos memorizar pero nunca va a
ser parte de mis herramientas que por
reutilizar cuando cambie el contexto si
entonces los invitaría a hacerse algunas
preguntas trascendentales y sencillas
que me gusta que me apasiona que me
genera esa necesidad de entender cómo
funciona
y por un ratito olvidarse algunas
preguntas cómo y de qué trabajar si
aprendo esto y en qué soy bueno porque
eso también es de contexto y está
cambiando todo el tiempo entonces
conozcan sea ustedes mismos y sean fiel
a eso y es importante conocer a ti mismo
creo por otro motivo más y mucho más
práctico aprender es un proceso personal
que se ensaya se ejercita y se corrige y
acá lo único que queda es hacer mi
propia estrategia de aprendizaje como
aprendo voy mejor de mañana mejor de
tarde clases tutoriales en grupo solo
con música sin música cree en su propia
estrategia y ahí ensayar cerrar y
corregir
ya estamos con esto no no soy tan
ingenuo creo que falta todavía otro
actor muy importante y vuelvo a lo que
decía al principio vamos a estar mucho
tiempo aprendiendo en el trabajo y acá
el mundo del trabajo como tercer actor
el foro económico mundial estimó para
fines de 2018 que casi que la mitad de
los trabajadores para el 2022 o sea
ahora nomás va a tener que entrenarse
para que las empresas puedan seguir
compitiendo entonces lo que queda
preguntarse es mi empresa es un buen
lugar para aprender si hay que producir
sea lo sé pero es un buen espacio para
ensayar para probar cosas nuevas para
equivocarse y aprender porque tengo lo
para contarle a las empresas usted
necesitan que sus colaboradores aprendan
y que lo hagan mientras trabajan
como les contaba desde hace cuatro años
está trabajando en anima en una
institución educativa donde creamos una
propuesta para que los jóvenes compartan
estos dos mundos mientras están
terminando el secundario
y en esta experiencia hemos encontrado
que cuando estos dos mundos se acercan
cooperan y colaboran los actores se
transforman los jóvenes se encuentran lo
que les gusta porque lo ensayan lo
escuchan en clase lo ensayan los profes
se desafían haciendo clases reales y
desafían a los jóvenes y las empresas se
encuentran que enseñando también
aprenden y es realmente tú seas mante no
más ahora antes de irme ve a una profe
de química tenía que dar
reciclaje y no se le ocurrió mejor idea
que que los jóvenes propongan las
empresas que trabajan con nosotros una
política de reciclaje adentro de la
empresa para que la puedan aplicar
sinergia pura entre mundos que cooperan
hoy hay 66 empresas que están trabajando
con nosotros para acercar estos mundos y
no ha sido para nada fácil hemos tenido
que hacer de cuenta un montón de gente
que el desafío aprendizaje permanente
nos involucra a todos y a todos por
igual y que la única manera de transitar
los cooperando y dialogando
claro esto supone salir de zonas de
confort
eliminar prejuicios que traía mover un
poquitito de cómo se hacían las cosas
antes solo porque así se hacían siempre
y salir a investigar y aprobar y ese es
un gran desafío pero tengo una muy buena
noticia para todos eso también se
aprende muchas gracias
[Aplausos]